The study of online behavior often focuses on the negative, such as cyberbullying or cyber attacks. But psychologist Dana Klasanan is studying the ways people are using the internet to help others. She calls it digital altruism. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. Dana Klesanin studies and designs media and interactive technologies that encourage people to live consciously. Dr. Klasanin is currently investigating the impact. the internet and social media have on heroism. She is the designer of an award-winning online game,
对网络行为的研究通常聚焦于消极方面，例如网络霸凌或网络攻击。但心理学家达娜·克拉萨宁正在研究人们如何利用互联网帮助他人。她称之为数字利他主义。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这里是“心理学访谈”。达娜·克莱萨宁研究并设计旨在鼓励人们有意识生活的媒体和互动技术。克拉萨宁博士目前正在调查互联网和社交媒体对英雄主义的影响。她是一款获奖在线游戏的设计师，
the Cyberhero League. She is also the founder and CEO of Evolutionary Guidance Media R&D Incorporated. Welcome, Dr. Clisen. Thank you. It's nice to speak with you today. You study cyber heroes. What is a cyber hero? Well, a cyber hero is an archetype.
即“网络英雄联盟”。她同时也是进化指导媒体研发有限公司的创始人兼首席执行官。欢迎您，克利森博士。谢谢。很高兴今天能与您对话。您研究网络英雄。什么是网络英雄？嗯，网络英雄是一个原型。
It's a new archetype, a new form of the hero. And the way I usually define it is as an individual. individual who uses the internet or social media to help other people, animals, or the environment. You described something in your research called collaborative heroism. Can you talk about what that is and how it relates to the rise of social media? Yes. Collaborative heroism is my most recent area of research and really what it is. A lot of people have the idea that people who take action online, there's a nickname that was coined to to refer to that called slacktivist. And so it gives us negative connotation that people who are taking action online are somehow slacking off on taking action in, let's just say, offline,
这是一个新原型，一种新型的英雄。我通常将其定义为一个个人。一个利用互联网或社交媒体来帮助他人、动物或环境的个人。您在研究中描述了一种叫做协作式英雄主义的现象。您能谈谈那是什么，以及它与社交媒体兴起的关系吗？是的。协作式英雄主义是我最近的研究领域，它实际上是这样的。许多人有一种印象，认为在网上采取行动的人，有一个专门指代这种行为的绰号叫“网络懒汉”。因此这给人一种负面印象，即在网上采取行动的人在某种程度上是在逃避在现实中采取行动，比方说，
getting out and about and collecting signatures or whatever. But actually, research has found that people who take action online are up to five times more likely to take action offline and to recruit other people to take action. So the idea is that the cyber activity, the cyber hero, blended with the offline activity, creates a collaborative form of heroism that's more powerful than either one separately. What are some examples of websites that encourage this type of heroic behavior? Well, some of the social initiatives that I studied that encourage this behavior include the Kone 2012 campaign, as well as Avaas. dot org and causes, which is part of the Facebook platform.
走上街头收集签名之类的事情。但实际上，研究发现，在网上采取行动的人在现实生活中采取行动并招募他人采取行动的可能性要高出最多五倍。所以这个想法是，网络活动、网络英雄与现实活动的结合，创造了一种比两者单独存在时更强大的协作式英雄主义。有哪些网站鼓励这种英雄行为的例子呢？嗯，我研究过的一些鼓励这种行为的社会倡议包括“科尼2012”运动，以及Avaas点org和causes（它是Facebook平台的一部分）。
And how is this type of, these type of sites? Are they different in any essential ways from more traditional forms of heroism? Are they more powerful? It's very different than traditional forms of or conceptualizations of heroism because we normally associate the hero with risk to one's life. And with some of this online activity, you're not really. really risking your life to engage in it, unless there's a caveat there, unless you live in a country where the Internet is censored or you're in some way, you know, restricted as to what your
那么这种网站，这类网站是怎样的？它们与更传统的英雄主义形式在本质上有何不同？它们更强大吗？这与传统的英雄主义形式或概念非常不同，因为我们通常将英雄与冒着生命危险联系在一起。而在某些网络活动中，你并不是真的。真的在冒着生命危险去参与，除非有一个前提，除非你生活在一个互联网受到审查的国家，或者你在某种程度上，你知道，你的
freedom of speech and expression is restricted. I personally think that it's a very powerful form of heroism in a different way, but in, you know, any time that you can get millions of people engage together, you can create change. And that's the hope. Can you tell us about your project, the Cyber Hero League? Sounds fascinating. Cyberhero League is a game that I'm in the process of developing. And what it is is just a way to spread the archetype knowledge about the archetype in a fun way to young people. I hope that people will play this across the age spectrum, but it's just a way to put the archetype out there
言论和表达自由受到限制。我个人认为这是一种截然不同的强大的英雄主义形式，但是，你知道，任何时候只要你能让数百万 人共同参与，你就能创造改变。这就是希望所在。您能给我们介绍一下您的项目“网络英雄联盟”吗？听起来很迷人。“网络英雄联盟”是我正在开发的一款游戏。它只是一种以有趣的方式向年轻人传播原型知识的方法。我希望人们能够在各个年龄段都来玩这款游戏，但这只是一种将原型推广出去的方式，
and empower people to realize that they can use technology in this way. What does the game do? How does it work? So the way the game works is the player signs up and his goal or her goal is to earn the badges of our participating nonprofit organizations. Right now we have over 13 nonprofit organizations and we're aiming to add more as we continue the development. But what the player will do is complete a series of apprenticeships
并赋予人们权力，让他们意识到他们可以以这种方式使用技术。这个游戏是做什么的？它是如何运作的？所以这个游戏的运作方式是玩家注册，他或她的目标是赢得我们参与的非营利组织的徽章。目前我们有13个以上的非营利组织，并且随着开发的继续，我们旨在增加更多。但玩家要做的是完成一系列的学徒期，
and in the process they'll earn the badge of that particular nonprofit. So instead of earning fake badges, they'll actually be earning the badge of the nonprofit. And some of our nonprofits are acting to protect indigenous peoples, the habitats of indigenous peoples. Others have to do with protecting the coral reefs and still others have to do with protecting the night sky from light pollution. So we have a real large variety of areas that the players will learn about and take action
在这个过程中，他们将赢得那个特定非营利组织的徽章。因此，他们不会赢得虚假的徽章，而是真正赢得非营利组织的徽章。我们的一些非营利组织致力于保护土著人民，土著人民的栖息地。其他组织则与保护珊瑚礁有关，还有一些与保护夜空免受光污染有关。因此，我们有非常广泛的领域供玩家了解并采取行动。
on behalf of. So one of the novel things about the Cyber Hero League is while the player is completing the apprenticeships and playing the games, he or she is actually contributing to the towards the goals of the nonprofits. In other words, funds are then given to the nonprofits, and the player gets the credit for having, let's say, you know, saved an acre of rainforest or fed someone or provided medicine or shelter and so forth. So they're actually making a difference in the world while they're playing. Are you inspired by what you've discovered in your research? Yes, I am inspired by what I've discovered in my research.
因此，“网络英雄联盟”的新颖之处在于，当玩家完成学徒期并玩游戏时，他或她实际上是在为非营利组织的目标做出贡献。换句话说，资金随后会捐给非营利组织，而玩家则因“拯救了一英亩雨林”或“喂养了某人”或“提供药物或庇护所”等而获得荣誉。因此，他们在玩游戏的同时实际上正在对世界产生影响。您对在研究中发现的成果感到受启发吗？是的，我对在研究中发现的成果感到受启发，
because I believe that this form of collaborative heroism is empowering and the cyber impact is also important because right now we hear so much about the cyber bully. We hear about cyber stalkers. We hear about cyber crime. We hear about cyber war. We very rarely hear anything, any positive words that have to do with the Internet. And I do believe that some of the previous... research I looked at in digital altruism and now in the cyber hero and collaborative heroism help us to expand the way that we think of the potential of the web, that it can be used, and it is being used in positive ways. And in order to promote that idea in society, we have to have words with which to speak of it. Great. Thank you so much for joining us,
因为我相信这种协作式英雄主义具有赋能作用，而且网络的影响也很重要，因为现在我们听到了太多关于网络霸凌者的消息。我们听到了网络骚扰者的消息。我们听到了网络犯罪的消息。我们听到了网络战的消息。我们很少听到任何与互联网有关的积极言辞。而且我确实相信，我之前研究过的一些关于数字利他主义的课题，以及现在对网络英雄和协作式英雄主义的研究，有助于我们扩展对网络潜力的思考方式，即它能够被使用，并且正在以积极的方式被使用。为了在社会中推广这一理念，我们必须有能够谈论它的词汇。太好了，非常感谢您加入我们，
Dr. Clasanin. Thanks for inviting me. For more information on Dr. Clisannon's work, please visit our website at speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association's Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
克拉萨宁博士。谢谢邀请我。有关克拉萨宁博士工作的更多信息，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。这里是美国心理学会的“心理学访谈”，我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可留下评论。